Traduttore: Thiago Branco
Revisore: Giorgio Fighera
Da sempre la scienza ha l’obiettivo di
andare oltre le frontiere della conoscenza
e del sapere, svelandoci misteri della
vita e del mondo che ci circonda.
Curiosità, passione e scoperta dell’ignoto
rappresentano il motore
che spinge lo scienziato
ad andare alla ricerca del nuovo.
Lo scienziato è infatti colui che osserva
il mondo da angolazioni diverse.
Non si pone limiti,
deve saper usare,
sperimentare cose nuove,
ma soprattutto
deve porsi grandi domande.
Il mondo della mia ricerca è
quello della robotica bio-ispirata,
prendiamo ispirazione dalla
natura per carpirne i segreti
e tradurli in nuove macchine,
in nuova tecnologia più
sostenibile e utile all’uomo.
Viviamo infatti nell’era dei robot
che ad oggi realizzano la maggior parte
dei beni di utilizzo delle società moderne
ma che sempre di più si sposteranno
dal mondo delle fabbriche al
mondo reale, al nostro mondo,
condividendo i nostri spazi.
Ma quanto siamo davvero lontani da un
uso quotidiano e di massa dei robot?
Così com'è avvenuto per le
tecnologie dell’informazione
e della comunicazione negli ultimi 20 anni
del ‘900, quando abbiamo assistito
al passaggio dai laboratori universitari,
alle fabbriche, a un computer in ogni casa
e più recentemente ad uno
smartphone in ogni tasca.
E bene, i robot sono già in mezzo a noi,
ma hanno forme diverse da quelle
che siamo abituati a vedere nei film
di fantascienza, dove automi e replicanti
dalle capacità superiori a quelle umane
rappresentano una seria minaccia
per la sopravvivenza dell’umanità stessa.
I robot saranno nelle nostre case,
ci aiuteranno nelle attività domestiche,
nell'assistenza agli anziani,
saranno utili nel monitoraggio
dell'ambiente e del cibo
per il miglioramento della
qualità della vita e della salute
sempre di più saranno utilizzati
in campo medico
ad esempio nello sviluppo
di nuovi endoscopi,
ma anche micro-robot che si
muoveranno all’interno del nostro corpo
per diagnosi e terapie.
Macchine autonome che
ridurranno drasticamente
il numero degli incidenti
stradali, salvando vite umane
e restituendoci
parte del nostro tempo.
Ma la vera rivoluzione in questo campo
è la robotica ispirata alla natura.
Gli organismi viventi sono adattati a
vivere in ambienti mutevoli, dinamici,
devono mettere in atto delle
strategie in caso di pericolo,
delle strategie per sopravvivere, riescono
a percepire l’ambiente circostante
e tutte queste caratteristiche
sono assolutamente utili,
rappresentano le nostre specifiche
per progettare i robot di domani,
i robot che vivranno insieme a noi.
Molti sono infatti i robot
già bio-ispirati
realizzati dai laboratori di ricerca di
tutto il mondo e da aziende,
robot che sono in grado di volare,
correre, camminare, nuotare.
La maggior parte di questi robot
sono ispirati al mondo degli animali,
vengono chiamati
animaloidi o umanoidi
quando il modello è
l’essere umano
quindi studiamo l’essere umano
per realizzare dei robot umanoidi
che sempre di più
condivideranno i nostri spazi,
ci aiuteranno nella
assistenza agli anziani
ma anche rappresentano
delle piattaforme per i neuroscienzati
per studiare il modello di sviluppo di
comportamento dell’uomo.
Ma perché fermarsi agli animali?
Per la prima volta a livello mondiale io e
il mio gruppo abbiamo pensato alle piante
come modello in robotica,
per sviluppare delle nuove tecnologie
e delle nuove macchine che
noi chiamiamo plantoidi.
Alle piante infatti è demandata la
sopravvivenza sulla terra
attraverso la produzione dell’ossigeno.
Rappresentano la quasi la totalità
della bio-massa sul nostro pianeta,
hanno colonizzato tutti gli ecosistemi.
Tuttavia, non è stato facile fare
accettare alla comunità scientifica
l’idea che una pianta potesse
rappresentare un modello in robotica,
e molto probabilmente questo è dovuta ad
un’idea comune che tutti noi abbiamo
nei confronti delle piante, le piante
sono organismi passivi, non comunicano,
non si muovono, non interagiscono
con l’ambiente e con altri esseri viventi.
Esiste una sorta di pregiudizio nei
confronti delle piante
che fonda le sue basi nell’antichità.
Aristotele nel suo trattato “De Anima”,
sosteneva che le piante non sono
dotate di capacità sensoriali
perché non sono in grado di muoversi.
Lo stesso Carlo Linneo,
grande scienziato al quale dobbiamo la
classificazione moderna
degli organismi viventi, nutriva un forte
pregiudizio nei confronti delle piante
e a John Ellis, altro noto
naturalista dell’epoca
che descriveva la dianaea muscipula,
la venere acchiappa mosche
come una perfetta trappola
per topi in miniatura,
Carlo Linneo rispondeva:
“L’idea che una pianta sia in grado
di intrappolare e uccidere insetti
è assolutamente contro
l’ordine naturale voluto da dio.
Impossibile invertire lo stato delle cose
ed accettare che un vegetale
possa nutrirsi di un animale.”
Allora capite che il pregiudizio influenza
le nostre opinioni, i nostri comportamenti
in tutti campi, incluso quello scientifico
limitando le frontiere della conoscenza.
Lo stesso Charles Darwin, grande
scienziato, fu vittima del pregiudizio
e fu costretto a cambiare il titolo
del suo trattato da “Piante Carnivore”
a “Piante Insettivore” per evitare le
critiche della comunità scientifica
che non riteneva etica tale
denominazione.
Ma le piante si muovono, lo fanno
in maniera assolutamente efficiente,
lo fanno a delle velocità che spesso
non sono percepibili dal nostro occhio
e quindi grazie alle nuove tecnologie
soprattutto basate su tecniche time-lapse
è possibile accelerare il movimento
e quindi godere appieno adesso
della bellezza dei movimenti delle piante.
Le piante percepiscono l’ambiente,
lo fanno attraverso distribuite
capacità sensoriali.
Le piante comunicano con altre piante
per esempio in caso di pericolo,
comunicano con animali, funghi, batteri.
Tutte queste caratteristiche e molte altre
ad esempio le proprietà meccaniche dei
materiali delle piante,
le strategie che mettono in atto
per ridurre il consumo energetico
durante i movimenti,
ma anche le strategie di adattamento
all’ambiente,
tutte queste caratteristiche
sono oggetto di studio
e vogliamo tradurle in tecnologia.
In particolare ci siamo
focalizzati sulle radici.
Le radici sono assolutamente delle
strutture affascinanti che si muovono
in un ambiente molto complesso
e eterogeno come il suolo
dove pressioni ed attriti sono
già elevati in pochi centimetri.
Ma le radici riescono a muoversi
perché crescono dalla punta
la parte più distale rispetto al tronco,
crescono per aggiunta di cellule
poi assorbono l’acqua dal suolo
e spingono solo la punta, l’apice radicale
il resto della radice non
si muove nel suolo
quindi non c’è attrito.
E a livello delle punte le radici hanno
sofisticate capacità sensoriali,
riescono a percepire l’ambiente
gravità, luce, temperature,
sostanze chimiche.
E hanno un comportamento
associato a queste capacità sensoriali
che in biologia chiamiamo “tropismo”.
Quindi le radici si muovono
crescendo da una parte o dall’altra,
seguono uno stimolo,
si allontanano da uno stimolo.
E abbiamo cercato di tradurre esattamente
questo concetto della crescita
come un nuovo paradigma nella robotica.
Una pianta per muoversi da un punto
ad un altro può solo crescere.
Allora abbiamo cercato di
tradurre questo concetto
del movimento nella robotica
quindi anche il nostro robot è in grado
di crescere per aggiunta di materiale
e lo fa perchè nella
punta vi è un motore
che tira un filamento termoplastico
che quindi cambia le sue proprietà
viscose quando è riscaldato
e il nuovo strato aderisce
a quello precedente,
quindi il robot crea la sua struttura.
La direzione di crescita
è data dai sensori
che sono integrati nella punta.
Quindi anche il nostro robot,
come la radice naturale,
riesce a muoversi crescendo e a muoversi
verso o lontano da uno stimolo ambientale.
Per curvare il robot deposita più materiale
da una parte rispetto all'altra
quindi implementa
quella che viene chiamata
crescita differenziale, proprio
come le radici naturali.
Ma sono molti i movimenti in realtà
che possiamo studiare nelle piante.
Molti di questi sono totalmente passivi,
ovvero non si muovono,
non c’è un metabolismo all’interno,
ma queste strutture si muovono
grazie alla struttura dei materiali
all’interno della parete cellulare
di queste piante e la capacità
di questi materiali è quella
di interagire con l’ambiente circostante
soprattutto variazione di
umidità e temperatura.
Quindi materiali che assorbono
e rilasciano l’acqua
e dei materiali che a seconda
di come sono distribuiti
guidano il movimento delle piante.
Allora una pigna che si apre e
si chiude, un seme di acero che vola,
un seme di avena che
penetra nel suolo,
tutti questi movimenti sono movimenti
e strutture assolutamente morte
ma che continuano a muoversi
grazie all’interazione
con l’ambiente circostante.
Allora la nostra idea è stata
quella di tradurre questi materiali
in strutture artificiali che
analogamente a quelle naturali
si muovano grazie all’interazione
con l‘ambiente, quindi una mano robotica
per afferrare degli oggetti, delle
strutture che si aprono e si chiudono,
tutte queste strutture
potrebbeo essere utili domani
anche come una pelle
artificiale dei nostri robot
che percepiscono l’ambiente, riducendo
la complessità del controllo
e soprattutto il consumo energetico.
Questa è una visione del plantoide.
Il plantoide è anche nella sua apparenza
simile ad una pianta, ad un tronco
all’interno del quale mettiamo il
materiale da depositare nelle radici,
ha una serie di rami con questi
materiali che interagiscono
con l’ambiente circostante,
e una serie di radici
che come dicevo crescono muovendosi
allontanandosi da degli
stimoli ambientali perché il robot in
autonomia, in completa autonomia,
riesce a muoversi nell’ambiente alla
ricerca di sostanze di interesse.
Quindi ad esempio la ricerca
dell’acqua è un tropismo positivo,
il robot si muove verso lo stimolo,
evita però gli ostacoli
come fanno le radici naturali.
Hanno dei sensori tattili in punta
e quando vi sono dei sassi
o non riescono a penetrare,
la pianta gira intorno all’ostacolo.
Allora la crescita è l’altro aspetto
fondamentale, per la prima volta un robot
è in grado di creare il proprio corpo e di
adattarsi all’ambiente circostante.
Questa è la vera rivoluzione che
vogliamo portare nel mondo della robotica.
Ma a cosa serve il plantoide?
A seconda dei sensori che introduciamo
nella punta, il robot potrebbe ad esempio
servire per il monitoraggio dell’ambiente,
potrebbe andare alla ricerca dell’acqua,
di sostanze pericolose,
come inquinanti,
radon,assolutamente
pericolose per salute umana.
Ma potrebbe essere utile anche
nello spazio ad esempio
alla ricerca di nuove sostanze in
pianeti diversi dalla Terra.
Ma quello che è importante è che le piante
quando si ancorano alla superficie,
consentono poi alla
pianta di crescere
e l’ancoraggio è un
problema aperto nella robotica.
Quindi può essere utile
anche in ambito spaziale.
Nel futuro potrebbe essere utile anche
come nuovo endoscopio,
perché questa capacità di crescere
all’interno dei tessuti senza creare danni
al nostro corpo e ai nostri organi,
potrebbe esser proprio una nuova frontiera
quindi rilasciando ad esempio
sostanze come farmaci
oppure andando alla ricerca di
target di interesse medico.
Allora quello che possiamo vedere
nel mondo che ci circonda
è che forse non
siamo poi così lontani
da un uso di massa
e quotidiano dei robot.
Molte sono le sfide che
ancora ci attendono
e soprattutto nello sviluppo
di robot più efficienti.
Ma la vera sfida è quella di capire
quali sono le reali opportunità
e le reali responsabilità nello
sviluppo di questi robot,
soprattutto prevedere l’impatto che
questi robot avranno nel futuro,
nel miglioramento della
qualità della vita.
Allora personalmente quello che
io ho capito dallo sviluppo del plantoide
è che le buone idee da sole non bastano.
Occorre anche analisi critica,
perseveranza, determinazione,
ma anche collaborazione,
la valorizzazione della diversità,
diverse discipline che si
uniscono nella multidisciplinarietà,
che rappresenta il vero
valore, il progresso,
come riusciamo ad andare
oltre la conoscenza.
Ma la scienza ha anche un altro
ruolo fondamentale nella società,
quello di formare le nuove
generazioni, i nuovi talenti,
aprire le loro menti, liberarle
dal pregiudizio,
perché nuova conoscenza
e nuovo progresso
siano sempre di più anche
sinonimo di rispetto dell’altro,
del diverso e di
altre forme di vita.
Grazie.
(applausi)